Ok, guys, I get it. You want a chocolate chicken.
So, yes I m back in the kitchen today. Because of you! You called me out to make a chocolate chicken, so that's what I'm spending my day doing today.
I'm making a chocolate chicken for no other reason than to give it to one of you.
Just picked up over $30 worth of melting chocolate here. We got our acrylic case and our gummi mold all dried out.
This is totally clean and ready for chocolate so i'm going to reassemble this
thing, then melt down the chocolate using
this double boiler
I have a dish in a pot of water that's
boiling and this is going to be used to
melt our chocolate make sure it doesn't
burn
did you know i'm giving away prizes on
every video I release now when I upload
a new video if you're one of the first
people to see it within the first 12
hours there will be a link down in the
comments section that will take you to a
secret giveaway. Click the link in the
comments section--I'll have it pinned at
the top--and it will take you to a place
where you can submit multiple entries
and when the contest is over a winner
will be selected and we're going to ship
your prize and this works
internationally so it doesn't matter
where you live in the world you can
participate. A big shout-out to all
your subscribers have been joining
recently from the gummy chicken video
it's good to have you on board it's fun
to have you here and you are the reason
that I'm making this chocolate chicken
today you guys requested it so I'm doing
this for you can see it's had a couple
of days to dry out so this thing should
be ready for pouring chocolate. All we have
to do now is melt it down, and pour it in.
Guess I better turn that down a little bit.
We got six pounds of chocolate here.
So how do you join the notification
squad? Here it is step-by-step. First of
all if you're not subscribed then go
ahead and hit the red subscribe button
and then you're going to notice that
there is a bell right beside it
click on that bell. You want to click the
box that says send me all notifications
for this channel and then you want to
click save. Now when you look back at the
bell it should be ringing and that means
you're on the notification squad. That's
a good amount of chocolate right there.
There's a chance we're going to have
some left over.
Let's do it, let's pour ourselves some chicken!
Ooh that's beautiful. That just jiggles into place there.
Alright I think that's gonna be it.
Surprisingly that chicken didn't take as
much chocolate as i thought i was going to.
We might have about 4 or 5 pounds into it.
Ok so, how do you win the chocolate chicken?
Follow me on instagram and
follow me on facebook. Those are the only
two places where I'm going to be
announcing how to win the chocolate chicken,
so just scroll down a little bit
and click the links in the description
to follow me on instagram and follow me
on facebook. When you log into my
Instagram page you're going to see a
button right here that says follow. Go ahead
and click that I also post a lot
of behind-the-scenes and projects and
experiments as they're happening, so if
you want a heads-up on videos that are
coming out in the future, Instagram
and Facebook's a good place to see
that today. I'm going to be announcing
the winner for the chocolate chicken on
Instagram so if you're not following me
there's a good chance you're gonna miss
it you'll find me on facebook at
facebook.com/thekingofrandomfanpage
and all you have to do to
follow me on Facebook is click Like.
It's two thirty in the morning, i'm still
working on this video for you guys.
That is one heavy block of chocolate.
Don't drop it now.
This thing's been sitting in the fridge
for about 10 hours, and you can see
as it cooled how the chocolate sunk down a
little bit
there's a little bit of an indentation
in the center there. I was gonna wait till
tomorrow morning but I guess technically
it is tomorrow morning. It's already 2:s0 am.
OK, let's crack this thing open
I just took two of the walls off of this
acrylic box and now we should be able to
grab the rubber and there we go now we
can get to work on separating this thing.
Whoaaa no way... That's amazing!
Oh no! Snapped the leg. Bummer.
So to whoever wins this chicken,
I'm sorry I broke off one of the legs, I
was a little bit excited to get out and
try to get a camera angle and I wasn't
quite gentle enough.
Wow, look at that. Well there's your solid chocolate chicken, guys.
Now who wants it?
Ok, let's weigh this beast and see what we got.
Just about four pounds, that's
probably because that other little bone
broke off, lemme go get that. This is the
piece of the chicken leg broke off.
It does look like a bone, but if you look at
the cross section you can tell it's
definitely chocolate. And if we add that to
the pile, you can see that brings us
almost up to an even four pounds.
Now check this out, just for laughs I went
and picked up an actual chicken
container, to store this chocolate chicken in.
Now
it genuinely looks like the real thing
oh my gosh it's unbelievable. whoop--
almost lost it there. It's just like one
massive chicken-shaped chocolate bar.
four pounds solid chocolate chicken and
this is going to one of YOU.
so hop over to my instagram, follow me,
and look for how you're going to win this
in the next couple of days. In the
meantime, I'm gonna pack this thing away in the fridge.
So there you have it guys and
just to recap the three things you need
to take away from this video. One: every
new video I release will have a contest
where you can win a prize. Two: ring the
bell and select be notified by email
push notifications and desktop
notifications so you don't miss an
upload because you need to be at my
video within the first 12 hours and
number three
follow me on instagram and follow me on
Facebook because I'm a lot more active
on those platforms now than I used to be
so there you have guys chocolate chicken
in all its glory and it's going to one
of you and I'm probably gonna put this
thing to rest for a few days and move on
to new projects, I've got some cool
chemical experiments coming up in the
next few videos so if you like my videos
please give them a thumbs up it lets me
know that you liked the content you're
seeing and i'll make more of it so I'll
be looking for you and those in the
meantime thanks for joining me for this
video i'll be looking for the next one
talk to you then